La optimización clásica es un paso crucial en los algoritmos cuántico-clásicos
como el variational quantum eigensolver o el aprendizaje automático cuántico.
Sin embargo, muchas veces resulta difícil minimizar
funciones complicadas en espacios de parámetros de alta dimensión.
Mi nombre es Victoria Lipinska y en este video exploraremos
rutinas de optimización clásica para algoritmos cuántico-clásicos.
Los problemas de optimización no son sencillos.
Cuando aumenta el número de parámetros, también aumenta el número de posibles
combinaciones de valores, y ese crecimiento es exponencial.
En el ajedrez, por ejemplo, hay 64 casillas
y cada jugador tiene 16 piezas; después de que cada jugador mueve una sola pieza,
hay 400 posiciones distintas. Tras dos movimientos, 72.084 posiciones,
alrededor de 9 millones después de tres y cerca de
280 mil millones después de cuatro movimientos.
Si llegamos a solo 40 movimientos, el número de posiciones posibles
se estima en alrededor de diez elevado a la 120.
Jugar una partida perfecta requeriría explorar todas las posiciones posibles,
y este enorme crecimiento significa que recorrer
todas las posiciones una por una es inviable.
Esto se puede resolver dividiendo el problema en dos subproblemas más pequeños.
Primero, necesitamos determinar qué configuraciones del tablero
es probable que aparezcan en los pasos futuros de nuestra partida.
A esto lo llamaremos nuestro subespacio de interés.
Y segundo, dado ese subespacio, debemos determinar cuál es el mejor movimiento.
A eso lo llamaremos nuestro mejor movimiento.
En esta analogía, la búsqueda inicial a través del subespacio de interés
es el análogo de nuestro algoritmo de optimización clásica.
Una vez que se conoce ese subespacio de interés,
un algoritmo cuántico suele ser el responsable de encontrar el mejor movimiento,
dado ese subespacio.
Empecemos considerando un solo parámetro,
theta, que parametriza una función de costo que queremos optimizar.
Si graficamos la función, digamos que se ve algo así,
en el eje X tenemos los valores del parámetro theta
y en el eje Y está la función de costo.
Ten en cuenta que la función de costo podría ser un costo financiero real
que queremos minimizar, o como suele ocurrir en el variational quantum
eigensolver, podría ser una energía que la naturaleza minimiza.
Nuestro objetivo es encontrar el theta
que corresponde al menor costo.
Partimos de un valor inicial de theta y en cada paso de optimización
encontramos un nuevo theta que reduce aún más el costo.
Parece que sabemos fácilmente por dónde avanzar en la gráfica si podemos verla.
Pero la dificultad de la optimización es que en realidad no podemos.
Solo obtenemos el costo, una pequeña pieza del rompecabezas completo,
cuando evaluamos la función en el theta seleccionado.
Así es como funciona la optimización en general.
El optimizador muestrea parámetros theta y calcula el costo.
Como puedes imaginar, elegir aleatoriamente el parámetro theta para reconstruir
toda la topología de la función no es muy eficiente.
En cambio, lo que hacen los optimizadores inteligentes es calcular
el gradiente de la función en cada paso.
De esta manera, el optimizador sabe en qué dirección en la gráfica
debe avanzar para encontrar el menor costo.
Cuando el gradiente es cero, el algoritmo termina
y se ha encontrado el mínimo.
Este mínimo puede no ser el mínimo global.
Puede ser un mínimo local,
es decir, el valor más bajo de la función de costo en la vecindad,
pero no en todo el rango de theta.
En el caso de un parámetro, eso es perfectamente posible.
Sin embargo, cuantos más parámetros tengamos,
más complicada se vuelve la función.
Ya con dos parámetros tenemos una superficie,
y con cuatro ya ni siquiera podemos dibujarla.
Al igual que en el ejemplo del ajedrez, reproducir todas las posibilidades
se vuelve rápidamente inmanejable.
Vemos que es difícil minimizar
funciones complicadas en espacios de parámetros de alta dimensión.
Sin embargo, para obtener resultados razonables, queremos que las rutinas
de optimización clásica sean rápidas y precisas.
También deben ser robustas ante el ruido,
que tendrá un efecto significativo en las computadoras cuánticas de corto plazo.
Los algoritmos de optimización clásica se pueden dividir ampliamente
en dos categorías: búsqueda directa y métodos basados en gradientes.
Los métodos basados en gradientes requieren información sobre el gradiente
de la función durante el proceso de optimización.
Esto puede calcularse de forma analítica
o aproximarse mediante un cálculo de diferencias finitas.
Los métodos de búsqueda directa no usan información del gradiente
y emplean otras estrategias para minimizar la función de costo.
Algunos de los algoritmos de optimización más usados
en el ámbito de la computación cuántica son los siguientes optimizadores.
COBYLA son las siglas de constrained optimization by linear approximation
y es un algoritmo de optimización sin gradiente.
SLSQP es sequential least squares programming,
un algoritmo de optimización basado en gradientes.
Usa un vector de perturbación estocástica
para calcular simultáneamente una aproximación del gradiente de la función de costo.
En un entorno sin ruido, optimizadores como COBYLA
y SLSQP convergen más rápido que SPSA.
Los optimizadores clásicos tienen sus propios parámetros
que puedes especificar para casos particulares, por ejemplo, el tamaño del paso.
Estos generalmente se pueden encontrar en la documentación
del optimizador específico.
Te invito a revisar la lista de referencias a continuación para comparar
los optimizadores clásicos más actualizados.
Exploremos un fenómeno más, relacionado con
la optimización clásica de circuit cuánticos parametrizados.
Como vimos antes, un gradiente que desaparece en la función de costo puede indicar
que el optimizador terminó en una meseta sin características interesantes, lo que se conoce como
"barren plateau."
Un barren plateau puede deberse a muchos factores.
El gradiente de la función de costo correspondiente a un circuit cuántico
con parámetros inicializados aleatoriamente
decae exponencialmente a cero con el número de qubits.
Esto se debe a que el espacio cuántico explorado por el optimizador
se vuelve exponencialmente grande cuando aumenta el número de qubits.
Las formas de abordar este problema incluyen reducir el número de parámetros
y, por lo tanto, la dimensión del espacio subyacente.
Otra manera de pensar en el origen del problema del barren plateau
podría ser la naturaleza agnóstica al problema del circuit parametrizado
frente a un espacio de parámetros exponencialmente grande.
Diseñar un circuit adaptado específicamente al problema considerado
podría ser una buena solución.
Además del espacio de parámetros exponencial que genera barren plateaus,
otros fenómenos físicos también pueden originarlos:
el ruido y la decoherencia presentes en los experimentos de computación cuántica,
la expresividad general del circuit parametrizado,
o la no localidad y el grado de entrelazamiento de la función de costo modelada.
Abordar estos desafíos sigue siendo un área de investigación activa.
Habiendo revisado los componentes principales del VQE,
resumiremos el algoritmo en el próximo video.